Oh Bryce one of our good friends on the
show Jessica Chastain yeah she's talked
about people thinking she's you and it's
very sure do look quite alike here's is
Jessica there's there's you that's it's
like it is what Jeff said but it's like
really really really true like it's very
flattering to me like she's she's
unbelievable what I didn't notice I was
it was happening before I never you were
fake yes so I went to school in New York
I went to NYU and just went up to school
in New York as well she went to Julliard
and there were many times I remember
this distinctly either many times first
time it happened I went into a Starbucks
and where people would mistake me for
someone named Jess and so I went into a
Starbucks and I went up to the cashier
and I went to order something he was
like no Jess your your drinks over there
and I was like oh no I haven't ordered
yet and he's like like what are you and
I just remember being kind of like it
was like a little unnerving because he
was so certain that we were the same
person and then a lot of friends and it
like later in years to come would say oh
my gosh there's this there's this woman
named Jessica Chastain and you guys are
you know you could totally be sisters
and yeah and then what's weird is it
happens to you as well Tandy Oh who's
your look-alike Zoe Saldana I mean what
it is you know it's Ryan I think about
you growing up I love the told stories
about growing up because your dad it was
like he was training you for paparazzi
he was very happy yeah he was I was
actually the saddest moment in our
childhood and these are Uptown problems
was when they switched from film to
digital because to my father that was
just like every day was the lottery I
mean it was amazing because you could
just take pictures and pictures in pitch
thousands of them it could be like
thousands of pictures of just a meatloaf
that blurry
do is at the end of the night he would
email everyone in the family
all the photographs Wow yeah but the the
thing is this is back when like the
internet was made of a fax machine of
would like and then you would download
all of these things and like you like it
was so much material to download you'd
feel like the lights dim in your home
and I got I used to say to my was like
that can you stop you don't need to piss
in every foot like we don't need to see
the blurry photo of the ceiling you took
when you edit yourself II never did so
after a while and I I mean I deeply
regret this no as it as an adult male
I'm deep regrets of what I did but I
would take the camera sometimes in the
middle of dinner and I just go in the
bathroom and I just I just grab a quick
shot of my penis and then he'd email it
to everybody
Kathy uncle Tim
ramps got a few ago no I well that was
his concern which is what actually you
know in a weird way made the whole thing
work for me so after that he became a
strict editor so you'd get just two
lovely family photos at the end of an
evening not sixty thousand shots of a
you know mashed potato do you get sort
of children wanting you to kind of
delight them as as Maui all the time all
the time like it's constant it's always
constant oh you sing songs sing your
song sing your song and I do it and then
and then they cheer and then I go say
okay we'll have a good day have a great
day
the last day I I can't
I don't know
that look like a man who wants to I
don't know all right let's see
little kids go right into the rap part
and this is what the kids run so it's
alright listen kid honestly I could go
on and on I could explain every natural
phenomenon the tide the grass the ground
oh that was Maui just messing around I
kill Daniel and I buried its guts it's
about a tree now you got coconuts what's
the lesson what does it take away don't
mess with Maui when he's on a breakaway
and the tapestry here on my skin is a
map of the victories I win
look where I've been I make everything
happen look at that meme any man would
you think it did happen
you've got the three wars who did all
play football yeah but now they've
basically all dumped it and yeah so it's
Harper the only one left she is the only
one left and she started playing every
Sunday and I mean she loves it the boys
don't play anymore which is a it's
heartbreaking they were playing a bit at
our sake and they're great I mean
they're amazing I mean they're goofing
around with yeah yeah good they're bad
the talent but obviously none of them
play anymore so it's down to Harper so
she's yeah I took it to a training
session the other day and she's she's
running around and I'm quite as I
wouldn't say aggressive dead on the side
of the field because it's probably the
wrong thing to say but I'm very I just
get I'm very enthusiastic mixed team
it's a mixed team okay and so half was
doing really well she's kind of
dribbling with the ball and then this
boy runs into her and I was and I was
like what had I was looking around at
the other parents thinking how do I
react do I be a UNICEF ambassador
it's okay or do I be Harper's daddy and
be like really so just let it go easy
voice because you are quite posh you
mean a normal life they're really really
really posh though I'm not that pot I
sound posh you do when I'm not doing the
art no one in any way you gotta find her
it's a long story
Wow anyway the Eyres just got to move
out before I let in another lodger
coming Benedict Cumberbatch is also a
time traveler here he is in the 1920s
yeah crazy
you made someone very happy in the
nineteen twenties looking in a mirror
grab where did I get those bangs from
look at that we got if you want we can
recreate the look if you want to I could
I say I'm glad you said yes because
someone went to a lot of trouble to make
this yeah okay okay well to honor that I
must swear you do that bit you're so to
hurt you okay
so ready do it where do I look where do
you look
camera five there there yeah okay
[Applause]
you are nearly in this world weren't you
them off Wow make me feel great look at
this poster John you almost hit that
[Music]
choice Captain America but you were in
the costume and everything me got pretty
good yeah I got to the suit it was a
pretty big day for me
I was hurting out completely and I I
gotta say for a split second there I was
feeling really good about myself
comes up and they give you the suit you
get it I give you the suit and I was
actually putting the suit on I was like
oh my god this is so amazing and through
the hallway came chris hemsworth dressed
his Thor and he's like you all right no
I know
[Laughter]
No yeah when you see Chris Hemsworth
with next to no clothes oh you don't
want all of a sudden be like I want to
take my clothes
you